[Music]
hey everyone
bandit here i'm trying to sneak into
gerudo town but it's super difficult
because they apparently don't allow men
in here tried the front gate a couple
times but that didn't go too well why
they assumed i'm a man
i still can't figure out
but anyway now that we're inside i
wanted to show you something really
weird in the gorilla secret club
really it's someone but i'll explain
when you get there go on inside
many fans of breath of the wild are very
familiar with the not-so-secret gerudo
secret club in gerudo town
which is run by a single individual who
goes by the name of greta and
greta's got some pretty weird stuff
going on let me tell you
but first let's recap what exactly the
gerudo secret club is
since you know the game's been out for
over four years now and some people's
memory might be getting kinda hazy
if link goes to the bar in gerudotown he
can overhear a group of women in the
lounge area
talking about the gerudo secret club and
its required
entry password but when he's noticed
listening to their conversation he's
called rude and the ladies quickly stop
talking about the subject
if link leaves and enters through the
adjacent room though he can listen in
on the ladies continuing conversation
from the other side of the wall with the
password in mind
link can then walk on over to a
completely normal looking door in the
middle of a completely normal looking
gerudo wall and a voice will ask for a
password from beyond the door
if link gives the correct password he is
allowed entry and then
you as the player can see why this place
is so
secret the elephant in the room so to
speak is that the owner
greta sells armor made for vogue
men males dudes and because this place
is so
secret it's actually the only place in
gerudo town where link can wear not
woman clothes and not get kicked out
but wait you may be thinking what if
greta sees that link is a vo
and not a vi well it doesn't matter
because if you talk to her she reveals
that she can see through your disguise
anyway but ben says something
very peculiar right after this we each
have something to hide i suppose let's
ignore that and move on to business
now greta runs a pretty shady shop that
sells illegal armor
so most people just assume that's what
she's talking about and leave it at that
but what struck me as strange was the
fact that she mentions she has something
to hide after you've already seen her
store
it felt almost as if she's implying that
she has more secrets than what you think
you see
i mulled over this for a bit and was
about to chalk it up to just another
classic
case of banded overthinking things but
then i thought about something else and
it clicked you see when she mentions
that she is in fact selling illegal
armor
she also says that there is a high
demand
for such things a high demand as in
there exists enough buyers of items
such as desert vo armor to create a high
demand
for the products the question now is who
are the other customers
every time i played through this portion
of breath of the wild i really didn't
give it much thought at all and just
assumed since we never see anyone else
with either of these armor sets in game
that her other customers were unknowable
people that might even hail from outside
hyrule
but if you think about it the fact that
there are people buying gerudo
vow armor from greta already implies a
lot about said customers in the first
place greta makes several types of armor
this is proven to us by the fact that
she sells not only desert vo armor but
also the luminous armor
she doesn't ever say that her other
buyers are interested in either of these
sets specifically
but just that they are simply interested
in armor sets such as
these this means that the sets and suits
of armor that she creates and sells to
her other customers
don't have to look like the ones she's
selling in store here
secondly the fact that she said there is
a high demand for her
illegal products implies that her other
customers are purchasing
said illegal products in other words
illegal
male armor finally the fact that she has
chosen to market two
male buyers in the middle of not only
the gerudo desert but gerudo
town of all places implies that her
location is
necessary because of her buyers who
logically must be located not just in
hyrule but in the gerudo desert
otherwise it makes zero sense to open a
store marketed towards men in literally
the one and only place in hyrule that
bans men
with all these clues about her customers
in mind i've speculated that there are
two possibilities for who her customers
are
the first possibility would be fellow
garuda women we can see that clearly
even though the club is pretty hush-hush
somehow gerudo women know about it and
are interested in going there
since it's more of a store than what you
would think of a club being
this implies that her customer base
could be other gerudo the natural
question is of course why they would be
interested in buying armor fit for men
tiny non-gerudo men at that well as we
know garuda women have to each leave
gerudo town to find a husband at some
point in their life
should they choose to do so of course it
could be that these gerudo women
want to purchase sets of armor or suits
of clothing for the men that they would
marry
kind of like how the princess of the
zora people will traditionally create a
suit of armor for the man she wants to
marry
i don't know why selling men's clothing
for men that wouldn't ever be
in gerudo town would be illegal and we
also don't see this happening or even
talked about at any point in the game
even when we see a garuda woman and
hylian man courting each other at the
heart-shaped lake
but still the garuda women can't be
ruled out as possible customers number
one
the second possible buyers are much more
intriguing and i'll just come right out
and say it it's possible that her
customers are none other than the yiga
clan themselves
think about it they are a clan that has
a history of inexplicably being tied to
the gerudo
for some reason they decided to live in
the gerudo desert of all places and
their hideout is
literally in an old gerudo excavation
site and
previously they stole the thunderhelm
before the events of the game and
get this they're all shown to be male
you know vo since they live in the harsh
gerudo desert
you would think that they would need
suits of male armor that can survive
those climates that literally can kill
people
and wouldn't you know it greta is
skilled in making desert armor infused
with sapphire that enables the wearer to
survive the blistering heat
and she's also skilled in making tight
jumpsuits that are perfect
for ninjas there are also more than
enough yiga clan members to create what
greta referred to as high demand and
justify her opening a store close enough
for a comfortable business relationship
and knowing that they are in fact the
very same yiga clan that has stolen from
the gerudo queen and made an attempt on
princess zelda's life
greta made sure that her club is a
secret to everybody
now one large hole in this second
possibility is the fact that the yiga
clan are shown to have had these same
suits of armor over 100 years ago in
link's memories
which is longer than any gerudo have
been recorded to have lived except for
kotake and kaume from ocarina of time
but they're witches so they could have
used dark magic or voodoo or whatever
however there is one more piece of
evidence that may actually imply that
greta was alive back then
and it's crazy don't get me wrong but
weirdly it kind of makes a lot of sense
so greta tells link several times when
he talks to her that she enjoys how
lights look
at night she also strangely says that in
other places the greeting may be savota
which is good morning or savak which is
good day but in the gerudo secret club
it's always
savasaba which is good evening clearly
she has a weird obsession with nighttime
but it gets even weirder
she also very strangely says that the
light of the sun
doesn't agree with her and that she
hasn't seen the sun
in many years and that's it no further
explanation
she clearly isn't suffering from
albinism or any similar condition that
would make her skin sensitive to the sun
since as we can see her skin still has
pigmentation but yet she clearly blocked
out all sunline from her store because
it apparently hurts her you guys
this is absolutely crazy but what if
greta
is a vampire it's true there have never
been vampires in the zelda series before
but there are creatures that can't
operate in the sunlight so
even if she's not a vampire per se what
if she's not entirely human either
some version of knight creature that
can't survive in the sun and lives for a
very long time
long enough to have provided the yiga
clan with their suits over 100 years ago
like i said this is probably one of the
craziest things i've ever talked about
on the channel but it is weird right
like who are her other customers and why
can't she go out in the sun
and why would nintendo include weird
little details like this that are
just enough to imply a whole lot more
than what they say
anyway now that you've heard what i
think what do you guys think is greta
selling to garuda women
is she selling to the yiga clan is she a
creature of the night who has lived for
a very long time and can't go out in the
sun
all of these either neither or none at
all let me know in the comments below
hey guys thank you so much for watching
and goodbye like the text said at the
beginning of the video i have an
important message for my subscribers and
my regular viewers who forget that
they're not subscribed and that is that
i
am leaving on vacation tomorrow so
unless you're one of the super fast
people that clicked as soon as i
uploaded this video
chances are that while the majority of
you are watching this i'm driving
somewhere right now
west the that way i'm going to be gone
until right before e3 so hopefully
nothing huge is announced by surprise
before then
like the nintendo switch pro but just in
case it is i will have my laptop and
emergency recording equipment on me
at the ready just in case i have to make
a quick video or something i'm
to miss you guys but if you need me or
want to get a hold of me or just want to
say hi
feel free to drop by on twitter and
instagram i'll probably be active on
either or both of those
also big thanks to my bandit crew of
which i have a new face to announce
please say hello to paul g
who just joined up with my elite if you
watching are interested in supporting
the channel getting me to announce your
name and helping videos just like this
one come to life feel free to click that
join button located below or follow the
links in the description to my patreon
and merch pages
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day this is mass intended bandit
signing out and looking forward to
seeing you in the next one peace
[Music]
you